I'm curious how did you because you
mentioned the the mad house thing but
how did you even get started in in oh
yeah because I you know we're coming out
here to my 3D but I don't even like know
like anything about I guess your
background or how yeah how do you get
started in the anime industry to the
point where you can rise to and produce
a little actually uh I started in the
weird position so I was just fooling
around in LA and I actually volunteered
for an expo As an interpreter oh wow
seriously okay I met the producer Mario
myself the founder of that house then
he's like oh my God I was actually
supposed to after college I didn't say
that yeah but he's like we're starting a
studio here you should join us I'm like
wait wait hold on
I feel like I feel like you're glossing
over still a lot of no no one's just
like hey man yeah we're cool we're not
interpreting you did yeah we get people
we get people at conventions being like
yeah I really want to work for trash
taste we're not just going to be like
well come on in like you know it's not
that easy right so it's like was it that
easy or was it that easy no no mean he
he mariama has a really Keen Eye on like
looking at people right like he he grew
up his entire career after physical Samu
and that level Mastery creates a lot of
crazy people and yeah they really really
have keen eyes yeah how long did you
live in L.A uh I mean I grew up in La so
from six to yeah after college oh damn
oh wow okay so he's like hey come work
for me move to Tokyo and you're just
like all right well it was actually the
first come to the LA office oh right of
course yeah I started working at the LA
office a month later he calls me up you
should move Tokyo I'm like okay um that
sounds really exciting when do I do this
next week I'm like no I'm gonna give you
one week oh my God why was there like a
project that desperately needed
I'm just gonna [__] with this kid right
now
the real ones will do it this only
happens in Japan like this is like a
Japanese mindset of like we have to test
the determination yeah
he's like Yoda about anime
seems to just do everything now yeah
yeah
Under the Sun you know okay okay well
then that's him okay so what job were
you doing at mad house so I started out
as assistant producer for the live
action part of the process right right
so then um there was a project that
we're working with Japan the wachowskis
um were actually producers that's the
high Matrix yeah wow so they're doing
want to show with madhouse so I heard
about it damn okay I didn't know this
we're not talking about animatrix right
no no no there's something else after
that yeah comic they do they produce
called Shaolin Cowboy okay and by Jeff
Darrow and that they want to adapted
that into anime oh wow then I flew over
to Japan so did I ever get released no
yeah I was
like how many how many projects end up
getting canceled then because that's
that's obviously like one what's the
ratio to yeah I mean
there wasn't in anime industry there's
not too many projects that can't get
canceled well after it launches right
okay but yeah mine was a rare case right
it was International production
Hollywood's involved and a lot of moving
a lot of the what you're called the bank
bank was an uneasy at the time so right
right right I I'm curious how you said
you just turned up in Japan did he tell
you what you were gonna do a week later
in Japan or was it just like we'll
figure it out
he wanted me to be the line producer for
this show I'm like how am I going to be
in line for this without any kind of
experience what would it be my producer
of curiosity so lion producer if you
manage entire production uh under a
producer too so basically you'll the
producer yeah Jesus Christ producer
tells you what to do and then you go
actually you do it man this the other
guy sounds good the way better jokes and
then I mean he says that but it's not
that well he needs it so I I saw every
industry guest we've had on this like
the weirdest yeah Journey because uh
you're talking about it so nonchalantly
yeah that's what I'm confused so you get
here and he's like be a line producer
are you like sure or is it kind of like
oh okay I mean okay I have no [__]
clue
yes yeah yes
I mean I'm giving you a chance you have
to say yes obviously I do that but
you're like all right oh okay and then I
guess I assume that they must have been
happy with your work because they kept
giving you work no so actually oh God I
don't know my career at math house was a
wreck because I actually didn't know
understand what really what kind of
determination was required to be in
anime production right right so I
actually caught myself as a [__] piece
of [__] back then so
and now look where you are I started
from the bottom now we're here
I mean all the teams of friends that
made back then um that's actually now at
Orange so my fellow producer is
originally from madhouse two of them so
what's the what's the timeline looking
like so you you moved to Japan how long
is it then from being involved with this
show and being a line producer to then
kind of getting the opportunity to work
with Studio orange like what's that
timeline so I graduated college 2006.
um I went into my house then so 2012 I
left madhouse right I actually kind of
got depressed with the state of the
industry and yeah I kind of left the
industry yeah and went into Venture
company
[Music]
I'm gonna
and then you went from Venture Capital
back into anime yes I guess um uh
someone who I knew at PA works right was
very kind enough to say that my
perspective is very interesting so why
don't you work for us so I spent a
couple days a couple years there and
then went to Orange okay PA Works what
have what that's a studio uh they've
produced um
[Music]
yeah I don't know the studio does not
mean anything to me I'm like I'm like
boneless I don't know
so I'm curious what uh what anime did
you grow up with what uh what are some
of your favorite anime I guess yeah what
was the what was the anime that I guess
inspired you to go into that field right
I mean definitely Slayers
Trigun definitely yeah oh hell yeah hell
yeah Hellsing right that sounds great oh
those are some oldies that's three
bangers right there yeah